[Music]
it's time once again for the Oscars the
award show that everyone says is
irrelevant
until the nominations come out and
everyone gets pissed off all over again
hope you're dead now here are this
year's nominees for Best Picture half of
which the Academy may have even seen
before they voted based on a real-life
race war wait they didn't come out right
comes the movie you'll be watching every
father's day from now until they remake
True Grit again featuring Matt Damon as
racing pioneer Carol Shelby and
Christian Bale as himself and if you're
still wondering which star is playing
forward and which star is Ferrari then
maybe this isn't the movie for you
[Music]
here try this old version of Mary story
instead wait they're both Kramer how
that car V supercar LeMond of justice
from the director who won an Oscar for
filming a bag comes a perilous journey
across a world war one themed Call of
Duty map where each checkpoint is one of
the UK's hottest Hong's all in a
desperate race to stop the pointless
loss of 1600 men or at least delay their
deaths by about a week tops
that's all blended into one never-ending
shot capturing the horrors of war the
chaos of battle and the desperation of
never knowing when it's okay to go to
the bathroom during the movie and is so
meticulously crafted that much like this
sentence you may not notice that it's
been one long run on until part of the
way into it but by then it will be too
late to go back to the beginning and
analyze where the places are that it was
stitched together so you'll just sit
there conscious of the fact that it's
still going until you get so used to the
fact that there still hasn't been a cut
point that you forget you were even
looking for one until the very end when
it's over and you realize that while the
patches may have been a bit obvious in
some places it's still impressive to do
something that can go on for this long
without losing its entertainment value
uncut gem
he's fought the Gotham police Batman and
the Suicide Squad but on Oscar night the
Joker will face off against his most
powerful nemesis of all Martin Scorsese
in a knock-down grudge match to
determine once and for all if comic book
movies are real cinema or they're in his
words theme parks I hope not because I
do not want to take my kids to Joker
World Disorder of the Phoenix from Greta
Gerwig boyfriend comes a story about
Greta Gerwig boyfriend's ex-wife in this
thinly veiled retelling of his own
divorce only this time everyone has to
call him a genius genius genius his
genius is genius
he became a genius so if you like
custody battles mom hair and amateur
drywall removal you'll love white spouse
down first
he killed Hitler next he avenged slavery
now watch as Quentin Tarantino changes
history to save old Hollywood yay with
Leonardo DiCaprio as a washed-up star of
dad shows and Brad Pitt as the most
charming alleged white murderer since OJ
these old chums will foil the meds and
family killings any minute now
any minute well there he is oh no die
yet wait now we're watching TV what's
going on here summer of 69
it's been adapted four times for
theatres and even more for television
including an anime
[Music]
now see a version that returns to little
woman's roots a book you were assigned
in high school let you flipped around to
the important bits to cram for an essay
in this classic tale of four Little
Women and the even littler boy who's
working his way through them one at a
time with a powerful message for girls
you don't have to choose between
marriage family and career as long as a
distant relative dies and leaves you a
massive fortune oh and marry a hot
doctor anyway couldn't hurt
the Whitest Kids u know plucky young
racist Jojo rabbit loves two things the
promise of a thousand-year Reich and to
dance but he's not alone meet his pal
Sam Rockwell and rebel Wilson who put
the CA in Y in na zi hi and our guys
featuring double Oscar nominee Scarlett
Johansson Wow how does she do that
it's gotta be the shoes and starring
Adolph Hitler as you've never seen them
before
hilarious if you're looking for laughs
only one movie is the final solution Boy
Meets World War two get ready for a
Korean film about class and you two stop
listening look you only have to watch
one foreign film a year okay so put on
your glasses and strap it in as a
struggling family cons they're way above
the poverty line while working for the
worst kinds of rich people rich people
House Hunters International prepare for
a master class from actors Robert DeNiro
Joe Pesci Al Pacino and they're creepy
de-aged avatars for an epic saga
exploring the relationship between the
Teamsters Union and organized crime that
you're still working your way through
because you hear good things about The
Witcher and they just dropped a new
season of Terrace house and what's the
circle that looks like fun well I'm sure
the second half of the movie is just as
good as the first half let's just assume
it all ends well for everyone maybe they
even make it back to Ireland that'd be
nice right add to my watchlist
[Music]
starring the biggest trends and best
pictures this year
inappropriate laughter don't you think
that's funny class divides hidden rooms
cowboys and Indians
what do you burn a precocious kid seems
he's a genius you know I mean a once in
every 50 or 100 years kind of Jesus what
are you 12
I'm eight surface me 11 I know when to
release dates getting to a meeting on
time and you're late
what you leap and it was traffic the
second I do to attack the line shortly
after dawn tomorrow you think you can
get there in time
Charlie finally arrived two hours late
to pick up Henrietta Cole's mother's
house I was waiting for you how was that
- a clock is supposed to shout sharing
actors
and white people dancing
[Music]
also not starring the following
completely snubbed films that deserved
it in some kind of recognition alongside
these nine
[Music]
you like a little limp Biskit a little
biscuit I used to listen back in the
days
nice
the Oscars 2020 if Joker's up for 11
Awards
they'll have to show at least 11 clips
of it oh no this is a worldwide
broadcast what if people realize they
live in a society by grabthar's hammer
what a trailer in a movie so bad you can
literally never watch it and it wouldn't
make any difference this ish just got
real only weirdo sleep without a fan